now our newest crown miss nevada making
history as the first
transgender woman to win the title and
she will go on to compete for miss usa
title in the fall 28 year old catalina
enriquez is from las vegas
and she sat down with our reporter
victoria saha on her inspirational
journey to the stage
[Music]
a dream come true for cataluna enriquez
as she was the first
transgender woman to be crowned to miss
nevada 2021
i don't know how much of an impact
changing
or making history is i i don't know how
that feels to me it's just i
competed because it's one of my goals
and it's one of my dreams to be able to
be in this usa stage
enriquez tells me while growing up she
didn't know if she would ever be able to
compete in a pageant
when i was young i told myself i hope to
see someone like me on that stage and
it just happened to be i'm the person
that needed to be in that stage
but her journey wasn't easy i received
so much hate that i
prayed to just not wake up one day which
is why it's so important for enriquez to
be a role model for those who are still
hoping to be accepted
if i could just represent as much as
possible and represent those who aren't
always represented something that i
didn't have growing up then i think
i'm in a great path victoria saha 8 news
now
now enriquez also told victoria that she
designed her grand finale rainbow dress
all to represent the lgbtq community she
will go on to represent nevada in the
miss
usa pageant this november rhyme